oi meu nome é augusto e hoje eu vou
falar sobre a extinção das abelhas no
futuro da nossa alimentação a partir de
conversas com minha prima de salvador
que desenvolver um trabalho com as
abelhas nativas brasileiras sem ferrão é
que descobrimos que elas não só
produtores de mel do própolis
mas outro provas mas são as melhores por
realizadores do mundo
como sabemos todas as plantas e flores
precisam de da polinização para crescer
na terceira em ficarem resistentes e as
abelhas são os melhores e 7 para este
trabalho é os poréns 1 73 por cento de
todos os vegetais verduras e frutas
cultivadas mundo pesquisas americanas
demonstrar um declínio das abelhas que
começou em 2006 e deram o nome é este
fenômeno decide cola nikola de tesoura
o mal do colapso das abelhas milhões de
abelhas e milhões de comércio e
aparecendo ano como desaparecimento da
nossa língua deles
o desaparecimento das abelhas é uma meta
global a produtividade de alimentos
porque elas foi lisa um terço de todos
os alimentos cultivados no mundo
então como vocês podem ver na imagem de
cima
aquilo é um supermercado com o mundo
cheio de abelhas
já o de baixo é um supermercado com um
mundo sem abelhas porque olha tem muitas
poucas frutas como vocês podem ver na
imagem 100 por cento de toda a produção
dos amigos dependem da polinização das
abelhas 90%
mas também em 2010 e assim por diante
quando o desaparecimento das abelhas
poderemos não só perder nossa
alimentação mas também nós lindos por
mais de jardins
no brasil a 400 espécies de abelhas sem
ferrão diferentes
mesmo sendo cuidamos a linha de três
espécies em risco de extinção
mesmo só com essas três espécies em
risco de extinção isso pode causar um
grande problema porque dependendo
dependendo do bioma as abelhas polinizam
90% de toda a vegetação então isso pode
ficar pode causar o desaparecimento de
vários biomas brasileiros e biomas ao
redor do mundo em 2013
a revista time isso em sua manchete em
sua capa a manchete o dotal psi
depois o pf dão federal onde querem dani
bis
ou seja essa bela desaparecessem mundo
sem a deles
o preço alto pagaremos se não
descobrirmos o que está acontecendo com
as abelhas pesquisas no brasil e no
mundo inteiro aponta como principais
agentes desaparecimento das abelhas
pesticidas agrotóxicos
o desmatamento e as mudanças climáticas
sabemos o que isso prejudica então que
sabemos que isso pode estar em goiás a
tam da extinção as abelhas por isso
queria dar uma proposta de educação
ambiental de colocar uma comédia delas
encerram em cada escola que do nosso
país e não estaremos ampliando uma idéia
é tão grande mas também teremos 20
primárias e jardins de nosso colégio e
no futuro talvez desenvolveremos
agrotóxicos e pesticidas que nem
termina em espécie tão importante pra
finalizar queria falar essa frase que ao
prestar albert einstein falou em uma das
suas aulas
eu to be pcp fã do serviço dizer namorar
no modem foi isso levo ou seja saber
eles aparecessem da superfície da terra
o homem não teria mais do que quatro
anos para viver
obrigado